je voudrais qu'on fasse un point danse
avec les stars est ce qu'on vous a déjà
proposé la pointe basse avec les stones
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le matériel arrêté on va faire un petit
point danse avec les stars parce que
j'ai des nouvelles du casting est ce
qu'on vous a déjà proposé de faire danse
avec les stars manière alors dont
j'avais gâte
mais moi je suis la femme du patron
c'est un peu compliqué mais c'est vrai
que c'est toujours rose mais c'est vrai
ces petits produits c'est sûr mais j'en
rêve quoi s'arrêtera sspa et moi
j'adorais souvent il faut comme ça selon
des résultats non mais tu as raison il
ya du folklore j'adore parisot que ces
fanatiques qui est il m'était
respiration et soit tenable et
franchement dirait qu'ils attendent les
résultats du bac mon frère non mais
c'est une émission c'est encore le
dernier grand spectacle aparté pmp
évidemment à la tony est quoi ce
spectacle c'est d'accord ben non c'est
génial c'est un monstre en déviation
c'est formidable alors et alors je vais
vous dire je vous dire des gens vous
allez me dire s'ils sont dans d'halsou
pas s'ils vont faire partie du casting
de la saison 10 de d'als alors des
photos de stars attention première photo
oui ce qu'ils monnayent oui il sera
parti de danse avec les stars
oui on aime bien voilà il sera par les
gens dansaient questar oui voilà ils ont
été bons oui c'est la caution moscato a
mais il a encore yohan rien dans la rue
personne ne connaît
un peu plus de temps mais la commnauté
foot oui mais voilà après regardez donc
il y aura un gorille de légumes vous
donner des infos sur le casting lui est
ce qu il sait qu'il est ici qu on aille
alonso alors lui je vous dis c'est
pareil sherkel c'est un coiffeur de
stars
ah ouais aulas n'est pas libre à vous
avez vous réfléchi les avions même des
mecs inconnu alors jennifer est ce
qu'elle y sera non non non non ne sera
pas à la contacter à yann on la contacte
elle a dit non ayhan a qu'à moi non non
non alors il paraît qu'ils ont refusé à
y en a qu à moi non
c'est ce qu'on m'a dit qu'elle a mis à
mal par la nikos je sais pas monsieur
serait fou un sky à dacca mois menu rien
et c'est un lieu que ce qu'ils ont pour
l'instant
attention emilie touchard non non elle a
fait sur sap et boulangerie avec le
large en chalencon bah oui oui et on me
l'a dit ça y est c'est confirmé c'est
parce que c'est france télécom ladrière
bonne et que ça y est ils avaient
apparemment ils ont même appelé france
télé pour savoir si ça les dérangeait
s'il prenait pierre-jean a fallu quatre
ans de france elle a dit ça prenait
c'est une super idée ça les gens vont
adorer les mecs et j'envoie chien je
l'adorent aussi mis l'argent une drôle
va la vie de se faire chier un cathy
guetta
oui oui oui oui laroui danny way
attention nicolas star fût resserre
[Applaudissements]
c'est drôle quand la star fouzi non non
c'est le sosie berbère que j'embrasse
nicolaj l'adorent mais les deux
kenji chirac
non non il aimerait bien fait contre et
non il veut pas trop ce que ça à [ __ ]
bah oui et on termine avec un dernier
régis beunardeau marais vous êtes grave
numérique
[Rires]
enfin point sur le casting de dalt tout
cas yoann avait noué de l'équipe il ya
bien georges alençon il ya une ancienne
miss france a balancé maeva cook et
quelques côtes cassées mais elle sera en
concurrence avec camille sert florac aux
canaris de l'orphelin guinard dit
absolument une mission visant à dévoiler
les stars qui aurait refusé les dévoiler
lessard qui aurait refusé
jennifer khadija claudio capéo lara
fabian christophe willem bilal elodie
frégé christina milian mais entendu et
clément garin avait révélé donc c'est un
fossé clément guérin qui avait dit anja
nakamura a rencontré le producteur de
dallas le mois dernier s est même portée
candidate pour la saison dix mais la
production n'est pas vraiment emballé
par l'indiquent les autres rumeurs sur
le casting je vous dis capucines à naves
joachim sont forgés loana vincent de
dien victoria abril esther balding
sterling oui c'est la petite pastille
valda l'a cloué jouanny des dix dont
beto ans sandrine quétier et gabriel
groulx jean bouhey voilà peut-être il ya
quelques noms et oui
mais alors mais il doit d'idées petto il
viendra qui sera bien mais il n'est
juste le prg et au mépris relais après
on voit là mais ils restent bas et
d'idées preto franchement on va pas du
tout maintenant
le diabète est relatée peut-être qui
kiffe la danse en tout cas voilà on
voulait faire un point sur le casting